preise explodieren sie gehen richtig
durch die decke tag für tag also jetzt
nicht mehr nur punktuell sondern in der
breite da wird das leben teurer
und wir haben eine inflation ist die
größte die höchste seit 40 jahren das
ist alarmierend warum weil wir merken es
an der zapfsäule wir merken es beim
wöchentlichen einkauf im supermarkt
man merkt es bei den heizkosten und das
ist ein problem für die breite masse
aber vor allen dingen für diejenige die
in schmalen geldbeutel haben deshalb
hilft es auch nichts wenn jetzt so
kleine
stellschrauben wenn daran jetzt
gearbeitet werde durch die
bundesregierung dann rentner und
studenten zb noch raus fallen bei einer
entlastung sondern wir brauchen jetzt
eine entlassung dass mehr in der tasche
bleibt also der staat muss von steuern
und abgaben zum beispiel bei energie
beim mobilität muss er runter um es
günstiger zu machen zweiter punkt ist
die kalte progression ist ein
fachbegriff aber wenn jemand eine
gehaltserhöhung recht wofür jetzt kennt
hier dass man es sich auch wieder was
kaufen kann jeder nimmt der stadt und
gleich wieder mit und man muss sagen
herr lindner als finanzminister verdient
mit jedem inflations wohnen wo die
inflation hoch jetzt zehn milliarden
euro nimmt er mehr ein und deshalb
brauchen wir eine entlastung jetzt die
also ich stimme dem prinzip zu aber ich
habe trotzdem ein paar andere fragen
über die nicht öffentlich diskutiert
wird sie kommen gebürtig aus einer
winzerfamilie in rheinland pfalz wir
haben vorher darüber geredet zu welchen
preisen winzer wein vom hof verkaufen da
gibt es noch weißweine tja ich habe auch
einen abschluss gemacht dass hier so
einen
winter verkauft weißwein noch unter fünf
euro die flasche aber im restaurant ist
das zeug inzwischen tschuldigung
schweineteuer geworden weil da wird die
preise erhöht obwohl das zum gleichen
preis kauft ich will damit sagen gibt es
nicht eine entwicklung und zwar in der
ganzen breite des marktes dass alle
möglichen leute die gelegenheit beim
schopf ergreifen ihre preise zu erhöhen
weil sie ja quasi entschuldigt sind die
energie und der krieg und was da alles
rein kommt und
und die und die vorleistungen und die
zerrissenen lieferketten und alles macht
alles teurer und sie stecken sich die
taschen voll ein muss die neue technik
auch daher also wer jetzt richtig gut
verdient da bin ich bayern sind übrigens
ölkonzerne sind diejenigen die jetzt
auch calculator rüstungskonzern und
jetzt jetzt auch irgendwann warum jetzt
ja auch klar aber wenn wir uns das mal
ganz konkret anschauen zum beispiel die
glasindustrie sie brauchen unglaublich
viel energie für für ihre produktion
eben zb im
fränkischen wo wir auch in kürze von
glasindustrie haben die schließen gerne
die tür auch weil sie jeden tag drauf
legen wenn sich die preise sind aber
hier preise seien da oben ja das glaube
ich wir haben richtige liefe aber warum
erhöht da wird er den preis der den die
flasche weißwein zum selben preis vom
vom winter bekommt den preis für die
flasche wein in seinem restaurant um
einen viertel lust an der mieter die
kosten
zeitrahmen er hat aber auch höhere
energiepreise jetzt sage ich mal den
winzer recht du kannst auch erhöhen zum
teil sind die wind die deutschen
weißweine scanner es auch schon
ausgezeichnet worden
je nach der sehr günstig die deutschen
weißweine aber wir müssen klar sagen
auch für landwirte wird es so
unglaublich teuer nicht nur dünner nicht
nur zur unterhaltung auch futtermittel
und vieles vieles andere auch wir sehen
zum beispiel dass die getreidepreise
explodieren wir werden eine schlechte
und haben die ukraine ist galt als die
kornkammer europas jetzt hat die
bundesregierung 1 sie nutzt nicht die
guten ackerflächen was die eu kommission
erlaubt hat was selten genug ist dass
die so genannten ökologischen
vorrangflächen jetzt für nahrungsmittel
produktion genutzt werden können und
diese bundesregierung verzichtet darauf
das ist zynisch gegenüber allen anderen
ländern die hungern ich hatte heute wie
viele amerikanische delegation da gaben
nachfragen die können das 0 0 wäre und
so ganz genau was sie damit machen was
ich damit meinte ist ein fakt also es
geht mir dass meine dass es am ende
darum es gibt in deutschland oder in der
eu ökologische vorrangflächen dh die
sind für die biodiversität sie dürfen
darauf nichts anbauen auch nicht ein nc
hat sich die letzte biene so
so weißt du dass wir uns falsch
verstehen ich halte das für wichtig
blühstreifen ränder zu haben muss dass
ich aufgeben ja haben wir auch und da
sind wir sehr sehr führen und sehr sehr
weit so viele hatten wir noch nie wie
wir es jetzt haben in deutschland aber
dass wir diese flächen in krisenzeiten
wo wir wissen dass wir einen enormen
verlust an ernte haben werden weltweit
das wird diese flächen in der gunst
region nicht nutzen um wirklich kann zum
beispiel anzubauen um wirklich
nahrungsmittel anzubauen das ist aber
mittel dabei nicht alle diese flächen
oder nicht alle überhaupt nicht immer
aber
die einzigen
naturräume dies überhaupt noch hinein
und natürlich dass er nichts für nein
nein also jetzt bleiben dann alles mal
deutlich es sind nicht die einzigen sind
dafür da
sein so nervös ich habe die gesetze
mitgemacht ich war allerdings genau
deswegen sagen na ja nee nee nee nee wir
haben die gemeinsame europäische
agrarpolitik die cup und jetzt so grün
war sie noch nie so nachhaltig mit 4%
stilllegungsflächen das kann man sich in
friedenszeiten leisten und es geht darum
genauso wie herr mansur sagte nicht für
immer sondern dass wir dort wo wir
engpässe haben diese kunst flächen das
heißt kunst region heißt ich muss wenig
reinstecken um eine gute ernte zu
bekommen da sieht man äthiopien anders
aus zum beispiel dass wir das nutzen um
dort wo wir wirklich ausfälle haben die
kompensieren zu können es geht ums essen
für menschen ich hab das schon
einstellen
alles das jetzt alles platt gemacht
werden nein ich hab das schon verstanden
aber es gibt natürlich auch eine
verknappung politik es geht jetzt nicht
nur um die ukraine wo dann wächst das
korn herkommt ich habe letztens ein
interview gesehen von einem bauer der
mir gesagt hat dass die preise durch
verknappung es könne politik hoch
geschoben werden und das ist zum
beispiel in frankreich offensichtlich
eine organisation gibt die das mehl
kontrolliert oder die mehlpreise und
auch die ver.di also die die die
exportierende des mails aber das
schreiben weil ich gedacht da und die
politik muss handeln und ja ich habe
viele projekte die wir in den letzten
jahren erlebt haben für wohlstand
projekte
gehalten und ich glaube dass das was wir
in den nächsten monaten erleben wenn
viele menschen nicht mehr das leisten
was sie für das leben brauchen dass wir
wirklich ein instabiler gesellschaft
haben vor allem im bereich migration und
integration
die leute sind zufrieden aber in dem
moment wo sie unzufrieden sind wo sie
nicht das leisten was sie brauchen
werden wir unruhen erleben und das ist
hochgefährlich und ich frage mich warum
der kleiner mensch immer mitmacht bei
solchen preisen was alleine schon es
gibt viele demokratische möglichkeiten
einfach auch protest star außerdem der
mann war nicht mehr denken
außerdem blicken ganz einfach ich fange
allen durch das zu kaufen was man
wirklich erst naja und nicht machen ich
wollte ich wollte gerne zu der ursprungs
these zurück sie waren ja mal
landwirtschaftsministerin und kennen
sich deshalb da sehr gut aus einer
gesundheitspolitik wie wir gemerkt haben
was würden sie jetzt konkret machen wenn
sie jetzt regieren würden zurück zu
ihrer these was würden sie sehr konkret
also wenn man ganz kurz bei den
nahrungsmittel bleiben ich würde dieses
instrument was die eu-kommission uns
ermöglicht auch als deutschland nutzen
genau laufen lässt auch für für
lebensmittelproduktion nutzen bei allen
übrigens weiterhin umweltauflagen die
gelten während ich lebensmittelanbau
zweiter punkt ist kalte progression
sofort anpassen das heißt sie kennen das
dass wir am ende auch bei einer
gehaltserhöhung ich nicht in eine höhere
steuerklasse kommen und nachher weniger
haare ohne vorher reform aber ich wollte
halt an dieser sache kommt macht hat
auch was mann und drei betracht zu tun
aber nicht nur unsere tab und ganz klar
der staat erhebt abgaben steuern auf
energie auf treibstoff auf wenn wir
heizen und diese abgaben sind im
vergleich enorm hoch und dafür eine
phase wo ich ganz klar sagen hier
verdient der staat mit den steigenden
preisen mit und das kann nicht sein dass
das zu lasten der bürger geht um dein
letztes das wundert mich dass die
sozialdemokraten darüber nicht sprechen
ist ein hartz4 empfänger dessen hat vier
gehaltenes jetzt mal bezug bezieht sich
auf den aktuell auf einen wahren er
berechnet wird aber der warenkorb müsste
jetzt mal angepasst werden weil auch ein
hartz4 empfänger dafür dass nicht mehr
bekommt und nummer zum beispiel wenn ich
jetzt heute 100 euro habt kann was für
100 euro kaufen in einem jahr hab ich
nur noch 94 euro und dem zehn jahren nur
noch die hälfte